[Musique]
les vacances sont terminées la rentrée
est passée c'est le bon moment pour
réfléchir aux activités à faire après
l'école
ce week-end les villes organisent leur
traditionnelle fête des associations on
retrouve mélanie qui en a rencontré deux
et qui va nous les présenter bonjour
mélanie contente de vous retrouver
idem camille alors déjà première
question est ce que vous avez dû
souffler que vous est ce que vous aimez
l'eau alors pour souffre passera aux
messes ou dommages et oui à peut-être
cette idée originale pour vous puisque à
saint quentin en yvelines on peut
pratiquer de la plongée et oui pas
besoin d'avoir un océan où la mer près
de nous la palme plaisir oise propose
plusieurs activités en milieu aquatique
la plongée avec des bouteilles de
l'apnée du tir sur cible c'est ce qu'on
voit à l'image du secourisme et de la
biologie et les activités se font à la
piscine des clayes-sous-bois c'est
vraiment ouvert à tous les enfants de à
partir de 8 ans sous certaines
conditions comme des bilans pour les
oreilles voilà il ya des bilans un peu
plus poussée et sinon ça s'adresse
vraiment à tout public garçon/fille
savoir nager pas forcément dans un
premier temps parce que pour être dans
la plongée pour pratiquer l'activité on
n'a pas forcément besoin de d'être un
excellent nageur mais on doit un peu
être habitué avec le milieu aquatique
les cours durent une heure et demie
c'est une fois par mois pendant 45
minutes il y a un peu de nage d'apnée et
descendez ans dans l'eau ensuite c'est
travail avec l'équipement à noter il
faut que les parents soient présents 1
lors du court et c'est qu'on la reprenne
le mardi 19 septembre alors une année
coûte environ 100 euros
et tout le matériel est fourni par
l'association il faut juste avoir bien
sûr son maillot et son bonnet de bain et
pour découvrir à leurs activités le site
internet s'affiche en bas de l'écran et
les membres de l'association seront
présents au forum de plaisir ça
10 et pour ceux qui voudraient faire une
autre activité autres enfin une activité
autre que sportivement la nive de talent
à la rencontre de magicien oui et plus
précisément de l'association de
prestidigitation et divisionnisme des
yvelines qui existe depuis 2001 et la
découverte se fait sur trois ans et
coûter
la première année on fait ce qu'on
appelle du close up donc c'est ce qu'on
appelle de la magie de près il faut on
est vraiment à distance de bras si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi
après la deuxième année on fait du close
up et du salon et petit à petit on
recule et la troisième année on fait de
la scène donc la scène c'est simplement
la femme coupée en deux que tout le
monde connaît ou
comme on irait jde des grandes illusions
par exemple des tables volantes des
limitations
la magie on peut la commencer dès 11 ans
pas plus tôt alors une question de
taille demain complètement parce qu'en
fait l'association estime que 11 ans et
une limite pour être un bon magicien il
faut bien connaître son tour mais il
faut aussi faire deux choses en même
temps faire le tour la routine comme il
l'appelle mais ceux ci s'occupait occupé
par dans le public et lui parler là
aussi l'association fournit le matériel
celui des enfants n'est pas le même que
les adultes on peut le voir à l'image
merci beaucoup mais la nuit en tout cas
pour toutes ces informations alors